hi I'm Nirmal mala parka I'm a kernel
developer here at Wolfram and my talk
today is core visualization and it's
going to be about core features and
visualization functions in this talk
we'll take a look at some of the core
features in visualization functions with
a focus on some of the things that we've
been working on more recently so here is
the overview of the talk we're going to
take a look at some of the application
specific relations we have and then
we're going to take a look at the
features that sort of cut across
multiple visualizations or multiple
categories of realizations and their
design then we'll explore a little bit
of the core features with some simple
examples and then finally we'll take a
look at the new core features and
functions that you've recently added and
are continuing to work on so here is a
arbitrary categorization of the
visualizations that we have the the goal
here is to give you an idea of the
variety in depth of realizations that we
have so if we start with function
visualizations here we are leveraging
the symbolic aspects of the Wolfram
language to plot functions so we
obviously have a 2d and 3d plots but we
also have things like slice contour plot
or slice plots which are a kind of
combination of 2d and 3d we can
visualize symbolic regions we can
parameterize functions discretize
functions and visualize them in an
interesting ways
so so as you can see given any sort of
vertical application area you can have a
whole range of visualizations same with
data visualizations we have the whole
spectrum from the more traditional sort
of scientific plotting methods like
lists plots all the way to custom built
information visualizations like charts
so here's another category of
visualizations that target a specific
application area in this case the
statistical applications so here we use
the statistical functions in the Wolfram
language to transform the data and then
visualize these data in different ways
and finally we have Geographic
visualizations where we start off with
geographic data and then layer different
layers of information on top to create
the Geo various your plots and geo
charts so that gives you some idea of
the range of reservations that we have
and but really there are only like a
handful of core features in all of these
visualizations so to understand them
better I'm going to break them up into
three broad areas data based features
layout based features and style based
features so being able to work uniformly
with data across multiple functions is
important so there are basically two
core features in this area one is
obviously being able to support the
various data types that we have in the
language so we'll take a look at how
various visualizations deal with things
like associations quantity weighted data
etc but then we have the second core
feature here which is to do with data
transformations all visualizations do
data transformations some form of data
transformations and as we come across
recurring sort of patterns in these
transformations in different
visualizations we sort of make them into
a core feature and scaling functions to
get exactly one of them so we'll take a
look at that then we will move on to
layout features we've had different
layouts for charts for a while so that's
one thing we learn from charts is that
it's good to have multiple views of
these data in any given plot and so
had all these different layouts and now
we're moving towards making layout a
core feature and rolling it out to more
functions and we'll focus on the new
stagnant percentile layouts that we
added to list plot and finally for the
sake of completeness I'm going to talk a
little bit about the different style
features that we have because these are
the most sort of noticeable features
that give the unique look to the wolfram
visualizations but before we do that I
just wanted to mention a few sort of
characteristics of these core features
so we want these features to be a
general sort of solutions that we can
apply across multiple functions but the
same time we want these functions that
use these features to be able to
customize the solutions based on the
kind of plots that they're coming up
with we also want these features to sort
of talk to each other so
interoperability is important so that
they work together obviously but also
this gives us opportunity to create some
automatic behaviors that are useful to
the end-user and we'll see examples of
those and finally we want these features
to be scalable not just in terms of
being able to apply them to as many
functions as we can but also within the
functions we want them to be able to
scale with data and so on
so the first example that I have of data
handling feature is associations and
this is a data type that we have in the
language so we want to be able to do
something useful and interesting with it
so here we have list plot and if you
give it a an association a data set as
an association it's going to
automatically label the points it's
going to plot the points and
automatically label them with the keys
if you give it a an association of data
sets it's going to use those keys to
automatically generate legends so that's
kind of a nice automatic behavior to
have you can obviously override that
with options and customize the plot
like a third plug over here and then
there are a couple of other things going
on here that I want to mention first the
data handling features is implemented as
a core feature so all of the data
functions are able to understand data
visualization functions are able to
understand the various data types and so
they can choose to do different things
with them but the second thing is that
there are actually two core features
that are working here together one is
the data handling feature and the other
one is labeling so the data handling
feature is going to get the information
out of the data and pass it on to the
labeling feature and that's going to
decide how it wants to label these
different points so you have these an
amount of points in the last plot over
here and then the feature the labeling
feature is going to come in and see how
to label these points which ones to
label where to put the label so that
they can avoid collisions and you know
adding automatic tooltips and so on the
second example that I have data handling
is quantities Bolton language is
probably one of the very few languages
that natively supports units so we want
to be able to take advantage of that so
here are a couple of a few plots and we
are feeding them data that have units
attached to them and so we have the 2d
and 3d versions of smooth histogram and
they're able to detect the units and put
them on the axes as labels we also have
deeper integration of units with our
plots so if you look at the last
plotless line plot it has it has data
which is units attached and you can also
specify target units here which is in
feet and the visualisation functions
natively do the transformations on those
units and then plot with the transformed
units so you can see feet being
displayed on the y-axis for that plot
the last example that I have here is
weighted data and there are two types of
plots here you have a couple of
statistical plots up on the top and then
lists line plot at the bottom and we
feed in the weighted data to quantile
plot which is plotting quantile against
quantile and and it's looking at the
data and making the determination that
it can use those weights in the internal
computations that it's doing and so
that's it uses that weighted data and
then gives you the plot on the other
hand this line plot is being fed the
weighted data as well but it thinks it
there is nothing interesting that can do
with those weights so it's going to
ignore those weights and just plot the
data so in this case doing nothing is
also doing something and we want this
kind of automatic behavior to kick in
for the user to have a nice experience
using different kinds of data types and
visualizations so the second core
feature in data is data transformations
specifically scaling functions and we've
had different functions that had
specific implementations of scaling so
we've had plots that do log scaling like
glog plot and we've had bar charts that
had specific support for specific
scaling functions with option and then
we went ahead and also added different
statistical plots like the probability
scale plot which does some fancy scaling
depending on what the second argument to
probably scale plot is it's going to do
scaling on the x and y axis and I think
the Weibull distribution thing is
getting cut off there but it's doing log
scaling on the on the x axis and some
fancy log negative log on the y axis so
these are specific implementations and
then we made scaling functions a core
feature and in version 10.4 we extended
support for scaling functions to list
plots and then now we are extending
support for scale
functions to function visualizations and
we'll look at them in the next section
layout features again we've had them in
charts for a while we have a couple of
bar charts up top with different layouts
and we have pie charts at the bottom
we've also had specific plots that
target specific layouts like the paired
version of bar chart and smooth
histogram where we put the datasets
back-to-back and so these are kind of
specific implementations and now we are
moving towards making layout a core
feature and we've recently extended
support for plot layout to lists plots
which we'll also look at in the next
section I also want to quickly go
through the style features probably the
simplest one is annotations yet it's
quite powerful it's specifically style
annotation you can wrap your data or
your functions in the style annotation
it'll pick up this style and use that in
the visualization you also get quite
granular control with four different
elements of visualization switch style
options like plot markers filling in
plot style these are all quite well
known I'm not going to go into those but
they do serve as building blocks for
more sophisticated style features that
we'll see in a bit these years it's kind
of difficult to imagine Wolfram
reservations without legends but you
know it's we took a lot of effort for us
to make legends a core feature and then
implement them and roll them out to
virtually all of the visualization
functions and then we have themes and
themes are is a core feature that uses
all the building blocks that I just
showed you under the style features and
it's it's a very nice it's a very
powerful feature which kind of ties
together a lot of the visualizations
under a common aesthetic it's it's very
easy to specify with just a single
option and it's also a great example of
a core feature that is extremely
customizable because each and every plot
that uses this feature needs to go in
and customize different elements for
that plot to get the look that it's
going for and finally I just want to
mention labels we've had labels for
charts for a while and now it's a core
feature which we are adding support for
more and more functions and we're
starting to do more and more interesting
things with labels and men gave a talk
this morning
detailing how labels work so if you're
interested I suggest you download his
stock or talk with men so in so moving
on the last two sections I want to focus
on the new core features and functions
that we've added so let's start with
support for plot plot layout in lists
plots and so here you can see this line
plot using a stacked plot layout and
what essentially does is it accumulates
data in the y-direction and so then you
get plot with non-crossing curves and at
the bottom you can sort of clearly see
this accumulation happening when we you
apply it with the stacked bar chart from
the previous section extending support
for layouts to list plots has some
issues that needs need to be solved so
for example irregular data in list plots
is an issue when it comes to
accumulation but we are able to solve
that using using the way-out engine with
odd which automatically figures out the
interpolation of the points between the
data points that we have and then
figuring out which which of those points
it needs to accumulate
to to the data points so that's that's
the kind of automatic behavior for
regular data and we also have automatic
handling of missing data which is
considered to be zero for the purpose of
accumulation then we have special
handling for negatives and as you can
see we have data that has that's
negative and so if you look at say for
example the Third Point and the second
data set it dips down to the negative
area so we want to be able to sort of
separate those out but and we don't want
any crossings so here the layout engine
is able to figure out a nice way to
transition from that point over here in
the positive area down into the negative
area and give you sort of the visual
impression of continuity this actually
works better with the full stack list
plot which I'll show you in a bit
where we have automatic filling but yeah
this is able to sort of do that at the
same time the curve the second curve is
not crossing the first curve and if you
have more negative points it's going to
accumulate in the negative direction
this way and finally we also have
support for percentile layout in in
Lilith's plots which accumulates 200 and
because layouts are implemented as a
core feature all of the list plot family
of functions can now take advantage of
those and here you can see list log plot
using the stacked layout on the right
and a more traditional overlaid
layout on the left and again there are
two core features at work here so the
layout feature is coming in and stacking
the points and then the scaling feature
is going to scale those stack points
I'm gonna jump ahead a little bit and
talk about the new function to be at it
because it's really straight spin-off
from the layout feature so we went ahead
and made a separate function for
stackless plot so this gives us some
control over some styles so we can make
some unique styles for this and we're
just seeing the plot plot range a little
bit
we're also automatically filling between
the curves to sort of emphasize the
stacking the second metaphor we also
have a stacked version of date list plot
and you can see that a little it stacks
the data and it also understands the
date dates and in the data so again
jumping
feature that we added scaling functions
we've had scaling functions in in
specific implementations before so you
can look at the log plot at the bottom
and to understand how scaling functions
work a little bit here's a sort of
simple example we're trying to simulate
the log plot using plot so the first
thing to do is to log scale the function
and and then we are so here I'm looking
at the ticks and you know generating
some ticks and I'm looking at some
convenient range for generating those
ticks an important thing here is to so
on scale or invert inverse scale the
ticks so we get the values back on the
y-axis and so that's that's a simple
sort of explanation of how scaling
functions work we obviously need to take
a little bit more care in in choosing
the divisions in the intervals here and
how we generate the ticks and that's
exactly what the scaling functions are
doing and also note that we are scaling
the plot range here for user convenience
so that's the idea that's a slight
simplification of implementation for
scaling functions and that's that's I
once we have that idea we can sort of
extend it to multiple dimensions and so
here we have plot which is scaling on x
and y axes and then we have the 3d plot
density and contour plot scaling of x
and z axes also note that for contour
and density plot we have legends which
pick up on the scaling functions and
automatically scale so you can actually
see that the z axis is being reversed
and so finally I want to end with this
table that shows the different option
values for scaling functions we have
sort of named values for the more
popular scaling functions but you can
also specify custom scaling functions by
specifying a scaling function and the
inverse of it and this is essentially
what I showed you earlier with
probability scale plot which is under
the hood using scaling functions yeah so
I just want to mention some of the
things that we are working on we have
some labeling stuff that you can look
forward to in the future we have some
uncertainty visualization that's a new
kind of layout feature that we had or a
new kind of core feature that we have
and then we are also working on more
flexible layouts for four different
plots and charts okay so I think with
that I'll end my talk and I'll be in in
the booth downstairs for the next hour
if you have any questions and the whole
vegetation team worked on all these
features that I talked about so and some
of them are here so if you have any
questions we can try and answer them now
thank you
[Applause]